¿Hasta qué punto los Estados Unidos de América
están preparados para mantener su dominio
militar?
¿Ha puesto de manifiesto la guerra de Ucrania
algún problema serio en las fuerzas armadas
de Estados Unidos?
¿Por qué en Washington de repente tantos
analistas parecen inquietos?
Y, ojo, porque en el contexto geopolítico
actual están preguntas, cobran más importancia
que nunca.
Fijaos si no en lo que decía en 2022 el Almirante
Charles Richard, por aquel entonces ni más
ni menos que Comandante del Mando Estratégico
de los Estados Unidos.
Atentos:
C1(“Esta crisis de Ucrania en la que estamos
inmersos ahora mismo, es tan solo el calentamiento
[...] La crisis más grande está por llegar.
Y no va a pasar mucho tiempo antes de que
nos pongan a prueba de formas que no han puesto
a prueba en mucho tiempo".
Almirante Charles Richard, ex-Comandante del
Mando Estratégico de los Estados Unidos)
Ahora bien, ¿A qué se refiere exactamente?
No sé, al fin y al cabo, si algo ha puesto
de manifiesto la guerra de Ucrania ha sido,
precisamente, la enorme superioridad del armamento,
el entrenamiento y la financiación occidental
respecto al que era uno de sus grandes adversarios:
la Rusia de Vladímir Putin.
¿No es así?
Entonces, ¿Por qué parece existir de repente
tanta preocupación?
¿Hay realmente motivos?
Queridos amigos, amigas, el ejército de los
Estados Unidos es la fuerza de combate más
poderosa que jamás haya existido…
Sin embargo, la guerra de Ucrania ha puesto
sobre la mesa y acentuado algunas importantísimas
debilidades que ahora generan mucha pero que
muchísima inquietud.
En este vídeo os vamos a contar cuáles son
exactamente las 5 grandes debilidades que
hoy por hoy presenta la capacidad militar
de los Estados Unidos de América, la mayor
superpotencia económica, política y militar
del mundo.
[Pero antes, una pregunta: ¿te haces una
idea de lo que te estás perdiendo por no
usar Surfshark?
Lo principal y más importante: la seguridad
al navegar por internet.
Surfshark te protege cifrando tu actividad
online para que nadie pueda rastrear ni robar
tus datos; Bloquea anuncios y malware con
CleanWeb; y protege tus cuentas de correo
electrónico con Surfshark Alert, notificándote
si se filtre tu información personal.
Pero espera porque aún hay más.
Surfshark es la primera VPN comercial con
servidores en más de 100 países distintos,
lo que significa que puedes abrir un nuevo
universo de contenidos restringidos según
tu ubicación con un solo click.
Además, con una misma cuenta podrás registrar
TODOS los dispositivos que quieras sin límite:
tu teléfono, tablet, la SmartTV, el portátil.
[Vamos, aquí entre nosotros, que puedes compartir
la cuenta con tus mejores amigos pagando así
cada uno unos pocos céntimos al mes]
Pero lo mejor de todo: por ser parte de la
comunidad VisualPolitik podrás disfrutar
de un 83% de descuento y 3 meses gratis usando
el código “POLITIK”.]
Y dicho esto, ¡continuemos con nuestro video
de hoy!
(T1.
CUESTIÓN DE PRIORIDADES)
Los Estados Unidos se encuentran viviendo
un histórico punto de inflexión.
La Rusia de Putin ha perdido los papeles,
Corea del Norte es cada vez una amenaza más
importante, Irán está a punto de hacerse
con la bomba nuclear y, sobre todo, la República
Popular China aspira a disputarle la primera
plaza como la gran superpotencia del mundo.
C2("Las amenazas a las que nos enfrentamos
hoy son más formidables que en cualquier
otro momento de los últimos 20 años".
Mike Rogers, presidente del Comité de Servicios
Armados de la Cámara de Representantes.)
Quizás por eso Estados Unidos tiene con mucha
diferencia el presupuesto militar más alto
de todo el planeta.
Sin embargo, pese a ellos, algunos análisis,
como el de la Fundación Heritage, afirman
que, actualmente, la preparación de las Fuerzas
Armadas de este país es “débil”.
Estados Unidos gasta mucho, pero también
tiene muchos, muchísimos más compromisos
que ningún otro país.
Además, Estados Unidos gasta mucho en términos
absolutos, pero cada vez menos en términos
relativos.
Si tenemos en cuenta la inflación, los crecientes
costes de equipos y salarios, el nivel de
gasto de los últimos años puede no ser tan
elevado.
De hecho, si ajustamos los presupuestos militares
por el nivel de precios de cada país, por
ejemplo, lo que cuesta tener un soldado o
lo que cuestan los suministros, la historia
cambia bastante.
(Fijaos, por ejemplo, en este gráfico de
2019.
La primera columna es el gasto militar de
Estados Unidos, la segunda es la suma de los
gastos militares de China, la India y Rusia.
Como veis, el gasto militar norteamericano
es mucho más grande.
¿Pero qué ocurre si ajustamos los presupuestos
por el nivel de precios de Estados Unidos?
Pues ocurre exactamente esto:
La superpotencia norteamericana sigue gastando
más que nadie, pero la diferencia ya no es
tan abultada.)
Y en cualquier caso, a diferencia de otros
países, las fuerzas armadas ya no son la
gran prioridad de Washington.
¿No me creéis?
Pues, fijaos en este gráfico.
Así es como ha evolucionado el presupuesto
federal en los últimos años.
Como veis, el gobierno de Estados Unidos cada
vez gasta más.
De hecho, en términos de PIB el gasto no
militar ha crecido casi un 50% desde comienzos
de siglo, ha pasado del 12,6% del PIB al 18,6%.
Sin embargo, no ha ocurrido lo mismo con el
gasto militar.
Una partida cada vez más pequeña dentro
del presupuesto federal.
Fijaos.
De esta forma, el gasto militar cada vez representa
una parte menos importante del presupuesto
federal.
Además, últimamente el presupuesto militar
incluye partidas mil millonarias para cosas
como limitar las emisiones de CO2 y otros
gases de efecto invernadero del ejército.
Lo cual puede estar bien o mal, pero que está
claro no determina la capacidad militar.
Por ejemplo, este documento que veis por aquí
es el Plan de Implementación de la Estrategia
de Cambio Climático del ejército para los
años 2023-2027.
Y esto es tan solo un ejemplo.
Por supuesto, esta falta de prioridad tiene
consecuencias.
(Por ejemplo, los últimos grandes planes
de modernización del ejército se llevaron
a cabo en la década de los 80, hace ya casi
40 años.
Hablamos, por ejemplo, de la aparición del
tanque M-1 Abrams, los M-2 Bradley o los helicópteros
Blackhawk y Apache.
Sí, evidentemente, se han hecho mejoras y
siguen por delante de sus rivales, pero hablamos
de equipos que aparecieron ya hace casi 40
años.
Y eso es mucho tiempo.)
Y, ojo, porque podemos encontrar una situación
muy similar en la Fuerza Área.
Desde 1987 el número de cazas, bombarderos,
aviones de reabastecimiento o de transporte
no solo se ha reducido más de un 30%, sino
que hoy los aviones son de media mucho, muchísimo
más viejos.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la edad promedio
de los aviones de la Fuerza Aérea de Estados
Unidos es de 29,4 años.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
29,4 años.
De hecho, la edad media de algunos aviones
como la los bombarderos B52 o los aviones
de reabastecimiento KC-135 superan los 60
años.
La edad media de los F-15C es de 37,8 años
y la de las los F-16 versiones C y D superan
los 31.
Y, sí, lo sé, la mayoría están actualizados,
pero hablamos en general de equipos muy viejos
y eso se nota.
Pues bien, todo esto ha hecho que muchos analistas
tengan miedo de que con las fuerzas armadas
pase lo mismo que ha pasado con las infraestructuras.
Que pasen de ser excelentes a ser terriblemente
viejas.
Que como Washington tiene otras prioridades
sobre dónde y cómo gastar el dinero, poco
a poco los sistemas militares vayan envejeciendo
hasta niveles alarmantes.
Es decir, que el miedo es que el cada vez
mayor gasto social se trague todo lo demás.
¿Sorprendidos?
Pues no hemos hecho más que empezar.
Prestad mucha atención al segundo gran problema,
un problema que la guerra de Ucrania ha puesto
sobre la mesa.
Atentos.
(T2.
ALERTA: MUCHA BUROCRACIA, POCA MUNICIÓN)
La mayoría de las personas que viven en este
planeta saben que Estados Unidos tiene el
ejército más poderoso del mundo y que lo
ha tenido desde hace décadas.
Lo que no se sabe tanto es que llegado el
caso estas fuerzas armadas podrían enfrentarse
a un grave problema: la falta de munición
y de suministros.
Esto es algo que se ha visto muy bien en la
guerra de Ucrania.
Una guerra moderna a gran escala es y será
ante todo una guerra industrial.
Es decir, un ejército no solo tiene que tener
las mejores armas, también tiene que tener
garantizados los suministros, incluidas, lógicamente,
las municiones.
(Por ejemplo, se calcula que Estados Unidos
ha enviado a Ucrania cerca de un tercio de
todas sus existencias de misiles antitanques
Javelin y misiles antiaéreos Stinger.
Para que os hagáis una idea, a los ritmos
de producción actuales harían falta más
de 7 años para reponer el stock entregado
a Ucrania.
En el caso de los Stinger, si nos fijamos
en su niv el de producción antes de que se
está se detuviera por completo, hablamos
de más de 13 laaargos años.)
Y la pregunta es, pero, ¿cómo demonios es
esto posible?
Pues bien, lo cierto es que durante años
no se prestó mucha atención a la cadena
de suministros E. Digamos que lo prioritario
era comprar y desarrollar nuevos equipos de
guerra.
Nuevos aviones, nuevos portaaviones, nuevos
blindados.
El problema es que ante la falta de contratos
la capacidad de fabricar municiones y sistemas
de armas no tan “llamativos” se redujo.
C3(“Gastamos mucho dinero en algunos grandes
sistemas muy exquisitos, y no gastamos ni
nos centramos tanto en las municiones necesarias
para apoyarlos [...] Nadie está comprando
los sistemas de armas necesarios para participar
en algo que no sea una batalla a muy, muy
corto plazo".
Gregory Hayes, director ejecutivo de Raytheon)
La cuestión es que tampoco es que el ejército
aparentemente lo necesitara…
Claro, siempre y cuando hablemos de conflictos
como de Irak o Afganistán, donde la superioridad
militar es tan clara que no hace falta grandes
despliegues.
Sin embargo, si, por ejemplo, pensamos en
China y un hipotético conflicto en Taiwán,
la cosa cambia por completo.
En esas circunstancias, la necesidad de municiones
podría superar con creces las existencias
actuales y la capacidad de producción.
Por ejemplo, según una serie de análisis
y juegos de guerra desarrollados por Centro
de Estudios Estratégicos e Internacionales,
un importante think tank norteamericano, en
el caso de un choque con China, Estados Unidos
podría quedarse sin municiones de largo alcance
y armas de precisión en menos de una semana.
Eso es, por ejemplo, lo que explica exactamente
noticias como esta:
N1(La Marina De Los EE. UU.
Busca Aumentar Drásticamente La Producción
De Misiles.
NavalNews)
El problema, queridos amigos, es que cambiar
esto lleva mucho tiempo, se necesita mano
de obra especializada, invertir en nuevas
fábricas o ampliar las existentes, construir
las redes logísticas, etcétera, etcétera.
Pensad por ejemplo en el caso del misil Stinger.
El Director Ejecutivo de Raytheon, la empresa
que lo fabrica, dijo que reiniciar su producción
tomaría no menos de 18 meses.
Para colmo no se trata solo de Estados Unidos.
La inmensa mayor parte de sus aliados están
en una situación muy similar, con lo que
el problema se multiplica.
Echemos, por ejemplo, un vistazo al caso de
Ucrania.
Fijaos:
(Según muchos analistas Ucrania tendría
que estar lanzando cerca de 250 mil proyectiles
de artillería cada mes, si embargo están
disparando menos de la mitad.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque las 12 empresas europeas que fabrican
la munición necesaria apenas tienen capacidad
para fabricar 650 mil proyectiles en todo
un año.
Y en el caso de Estados Unidos, la producción
se sitúa en aproximadamente 20.000 proyectiles
por mes.)
Pero eso ni siquiera es todo, además resulta
muy difícil encontrar algunos componentes
básicos que estén fabricados en Estados
Unidos y no en países como China.
Lo que se considera un riesgo claro para la
Seguridad Nacional.
Por ejemplo, en septiembre 2022, se detuvieron
por un tiempo todas las entregas de nuevos
F-35.
¿El motivo?
Encontraron una aleación fabricada en China
en algunos componentes.
Pues bien, de momento, la Administración
Biden incluyó en su petición presupuestaria
al Congreso un incremento de más del 50%
para comprar misiles y municiones, con la
idea no solo de reponer el stock entregado
a Ucrania, sino también para empezar a restablecer
las cadenas de suministro.
En esta línea, la producción de proyectiles
para artillería, por ejemplo, se espera que
se incremente un 500% en apenas 2 años.
Ahora bien, ¿pensáis que
aquí terminan todos los problemas de la cadena
de producción?
Pues estáis muy pero que muy equivocados.
Fijaos.
N2(Según un nuevo informe, el proceso presupuestario
del Pentágono es demasiado lento para vencer
a China.
DefenseNews)
N3(China está recibiendo nuevas armas más
rápido que EE. UU.
National Interest)
De esta forma, el tiempo que el Pentágono
necesita para detectar una necesidad y adjudicar
un contrato se ha multiplicado por 7 desde
los años 50.
Digamos que el proceso se ha vuelto demasiado
lento y pesado.
Y esto nos lleva, directamente, al tercer
gran problema de las fuerzas armadas de Estados
Unido, uno del que ya os hemos hablado aquí
en VisualPolitik: la hiperconcentración del
sector.
Atentos
(T3.
EL CONTROL DE LOS GIGANTES)
Desde la caída de la Unión Soviética el
número de contratistas principales ha pasado
de más de 80 a prácticamente estos 5 grandes
grupos que veis en pantalla.
C4("No hace muchos años, teníamos cinco
veces más contratistas y había más competencia
y más creatividad", Ken Calvert, congresista
republicano por California)
Es decir, que con el paso del tiempo, lo que
en 1961 el presidente Eisenhower ya bautizó
como el “complejo militar-industrial”,
ahora ha quedado bajo el control de unos pocos
gigantes.
Prácticamente, todo pasa por ellos.
Si por ejemplo hace 30 años el Departamento
de Defensa podía contar con 8 proveedores
de aviones militares, hoy solo puede hacerlo
con 3: Boeing, Lockheed Martin y Northrop
Grumman.
En el caso de los misiles el número ha pasado
de 8 a 3.
Hoy por hoy, el 90% de los misiles norteamericanos
son fabricados por tan solo 3 empresas: Boeing,
Lockheed Martin y Raytheon.
Y en ciertos casos de subcomponentes la cosa
es aún peor:
(El Javelin, por ejemplo, se basa en el avanzado
motor de cohete de propulsor sólido de la
Aerojet Rocketdyne, no hay alternativas.
Si esta empresa tiene un problema o falla
un proceso de producción, punto final.
Otra empresa, la Williams International construye
los motores turbofán para la mayoría de
los misiles de cruceros.
Sin ella no hay alternativas.
Y así podríamos continuar con una larga
lista de ejemplos.)
Es decir, la competencia se ha reducido.
Y ya sabéis lo que eso supone:
Menos innovación, más coste, menos capacidad
de producción sobrante, menos empleos y mucha
más dependencia en torno a lo que pueda o
no ocurrir con una determinada empresa.
Pero, ¿queréis un ejemplo concreto?
Pues veréis, según datos del propio gobierno
de Estados Unidos, las pequeñas empresas
generan 16,5 veces más patentes que los grandes
gigantes corporativos.
Sin embargo, durante la última década el
número de pequeñas empresas en el complejo
industrial militar norteamericano se ha reducido
un 40%.
Pero como sobre este tema ya os hablamos largo
y tendido en un vídeo que os dejamos en la
descripción, pasemos ya al CUARTO gran problema
que hoy por hoy tienen las fuerzas armadas
de Estados Unidos.
¿Alguna idea de por donde van los tiros?
Pues…
Atentos.
(T4.
ANIRAM AL NE ETATSILA)
Mano de obra, así de sencillo, hace falta
mano de obra.
Estados Unidos está atravesando su peor racha
de reclutamiento desde 1973.
2022 fue un año malo y 2023 parece que lo
va a ser aún peor.
Por ejemplo, en el ejercicio 2 b 022, el Ejército
de Tierra se quedó 15.000 soldados por debajo
de su objetivo de tropas.
En 2023 el número de efectivos puede reducirse
en cerca 20.000 unidades.
De esta forma se espera que el ejercicio 2023
cierre con unos 450 mil soldados, frente algo
más de 500 mil que se consideran necesarios.
Y no se trata solo del US Army, el resto de
cuerpos están en una situación muy parecida.
Incluso las academias militares se están
viendo afectadas por esta crisis.
Por ejemplo, Las solicitudes a la Academia
de la Fuerza Aérea han caído un 28 %,
las de la Academia Naval un 20% y West Point
un 10 (%)
Esto exactamente lo que explica noticias como
esta:
N4(La Armada cancela las bajas anticipadas
y ofrece prórrogas para que más marineros
sigan vistiendo el uniforme.
Military.com)
Queridos amigos, amigas, en Estados Unidos
hay trabajo, la tasa de desempleo está en
prácticamente en mínimos históricos y eso
se nota.
La competencia por los jóvenes trabajadores
es muy alta, y las fuerzas armadas no escapan
de esa dinámica.
Pero ese no es el único problema.
El grupo de jóvenes calificados para unirse
a las fuerzas armadas sin necesitar ninguna
excepción es cada vez más y más pequeño:
problemas de visión, de asma, de salud mental,
de obesidad, antecedentes…
Desde el 2016 se ha pasado del 29 al 23%.
Para colmo por diferentes motivos las fuerzas
armadas no están atravesando su mejor momento
en términos de popularidad.
Algunas encuestas muestran que el nivel de
confianza en esta institución ha caído bastante
en los últimos años, lo que hace que sea
un destino mucho menos atractivo.
N5(Encuesta: la confianza en las fuerzas armadas
de EE.UU. se mantiene por debajo del 50 %.
Alrededor del 48% de los estadounidenses dicen
tener mucha confianza en el ejército, ligeramente
por encima del 45% del año pasado.
La confianza en el ejército estadounidense
se ha desplomado en los últimos años.
En 2018, alrededor del 70 % de los estadounidenses
dijeron que tenían mucha confianza en la
institución.
The Hill)
Y por último tenemos el quinto gran problema.
Ni más ni menos que este:
(T5.
NUEVAS AMENAZAS Y NUEVAS NECESIDADES)
A ver, no nos malinterpretes, pese a todos
los problemas que hemos visto, las fuerzas
armadas de Estados Unidos están a otro nivel.
Sin embargo, eso no quiere decir que no tengan
grietas, como ya habéis visto las tienen.
Pues bien, a todos esos problemas tenemos
que sumar otra cuestión: las nuevas necesidades
operativas.
Hemos hablado de ello en un montón de vídeos
aquí en VisualPolitik:
China está modernizando su ejército a toda
pastilla y tiene una política exterior cada
vez más agresiva.
Rusia se acaba de convertir en un adversario
muy poco fiable que además ha suspendido
el acuerdo New Start que limita el número
total de ojivas nucleares desplegadas.
La Guerra de Ucrania ha puesto de manifiesto
muchas debilidades que ahora se necesitan
superar urgentemente.
Corea del Norte se está convirtiendo en una
creciente amenaza nuclear e Irán parece muy
cerca de hacerse también con la bomba.
N6(Northcom: EE.UU. asumirá un "mayor riesgo"
contra los misiles balísticos intercontinentales
norcoreanos en 2025.
Inside Defense)
Todo esto conllevará, por ejemplo, tener
que multiplicar el sistema de defensa antimisiles.
Porque estas nuevas capacidades apuntan ya
directamente al propio territorio de Estados
Unidos.
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
Si en la década de los 80 la Administración
Reagan anunció la Iniciativa de Defensa Estratégica,
popularmente como Star Wars y que contemplaba
cientos y cientos de interceptores terrestres
y espaciales, montados en satélites, hoy
Estados Unidos apenas cuenta con poco más
de 40 interceptores terrestres.
Ponerse al día supondrá, por supuesto, mucho
dinero y muchas energías.
Y este es tan solo un ejemplo.
Pues bien, aunque Estados Unidos es el país
que más gasta en defensa y que tiene con
mucha diferencia la mejor y más poderosa
fuerza militar, estos que habéis visto son
los 5 grandes p roblemas a los que se enfrentan
hoy por hoy las Fuerzas Armadas de Estados
Unidos para cumplir su gran objetivo: seguir
manteniendo una enorme superioridad militar
respecto a cualquier adversario.
Por supuesto tener a tus espaldas los bombarderos
B1 y B2, los 180 furtivos F22, los F35, los
apache, los submarinos clase Ohio y clase
Virginia, los misiles Tomahawk, los portaaviones
clase Nimitz y clase Ford, los Abrams, los
más de 400 Himars o los cerca de 1.000 M270
te hacen ser un rival formidable y tal vez
invencible, pero ya veis que todo se puede
mejorar.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Creéis que Estados Unidos mantendrá su
hegemonía mundial durante las próximas décadas?
¿Cuál pensáis que es el mayor problema
de todos?
¿Logrará China ponerse a su altura?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ya sabéis, si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
a VisualPolitik.
Y recordad, con el código “POLITIK” acabado
en “K” podréis disfrutar de un 83% de
descuento y 3 meses gratis de Surfshark.
El link, como siempre, en la descripción.
Una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.